[Music]
how'd our YouTube chess lovers in our
France
this is guns in here welcome to the 16th
episode of my dirty chess tricks against
Sicilian in this episode I'm going to
show you so the nice and cool tricks in
the classical NOS turf from the white
perspective where black commits to move
six ePHI the opening arises after the
following model Evo c5 Knight to f3 d6
d4 C captors d4 Knight captures d4
Knight to f6 Knight to c3 and now this
traumatic new a6 controlling the b phi
square ok the classical na stroke start
with Bishop to e2 so as you can see I
have highlighted by the arrows very
simple but effective plan of campaign by
white what he wants to do is he wants to
play Bishop to e3 castle on the Kings
side and then later one push forward
with the F pawn and generate a King side
attack now in the last episode I have
covered the movie 6 so if you haven't
check it out
I strongly insist you to watch that
episode however in this episode we are
going to concentrate on one of the most
popular choice by black namely ePHI so
what black is hoping for is an improved
version of sveshnikov sicilian where
this knight cannot go to the b phi
square as per the database Knight to b3
and Knight to f3 are the most common
reply however nmap is sword I always
deliver a surprise package and here my
recommendation is this very cunning move
Knight to a5 which involves lot of
traits and black has to know exactly
how he is going to handle the scenario
now as for the Sicilian theory this move
has been dismissed by all here Titian
the simple reason is in almost all the
Sicilians the break which black is
looking for is defy and by playing
Knight to a5 white has actually allowed
this anyways if you check this position
in online database there are hundred and
seventy-two games played with this line
and yes I am highlighted over here there
are two popular choice by a black namely
defy and Bishop captures f5 now before
we look at them there are few other
things we need to know that other
sideline moves such as g6 are not good
at all
the simple reason is after Knight - III
white is going to cement a piece on d5
which is not easy to stop and in all
this lines white get superior piece play
well same goes for the move Knight
captures evil which at first sight looks
very good because it winds upon
tactically but after White's next reply
Knight captures g7 Czech and after
Bishop captures g7 and the Moon Knight
captures defy not only White has active
piece development but black King safety
has been compromised and no matter
whichever side the King will go there
are always some holes to attack the poor
King so considering all these factors
let's start with blacks two most popular
choice and the first move I want to
consider is defy which is very natural
and you can literally expect from 80% of
your opponent and against it we are
going to continue with Bishop to g5 so
attack on d5 and black responses force
he has to play either the Moody fool or
take on Eve
well taking money for is a pretty bad
one and we have the phosphoric on the
table white can go with this forcing
sequence Queen takes Queen King takes
now castle on the Queen side with a
check and if any piece comes in between
the resulting position is quite
favorable to the white camp
so if black wants to keep his slight
advantage then he has to play King to c7
in order to hang on to his extra pawn
well at first sight this position looks
not that great as White is a clear pond
down but here White has this tactical
resource Knight captures g7 which not
only regained the pawn but it also
doubled the black pawn which later on
can become clear-cut akut if black
doesn't capture the piece then obviously
white is better and the tactical point
is if black go ahead and take this
Knight
then after Bishop captures f6 Bishop
captures f6 and the move Knight to d5
we are regaining the piece with interest
so that is what happened if black
capture on e fo monitor response is d
for attacking unit but here white has in
between mu namely Bishop captures f6 if
G capture sub 6 then black will get
double porn and his King safety is an
issue so initially black has to capture
with the Queen afterwards we are going
to come forward with Knight to d5 to
threat so black has only response Queen
to d8 or else and we reach to one of the
most important position of this line it
is very important to understand that
white cannot castle here the simple
reason is after Bishop captures fi white
indeed lose a piece so that is right out
of the equation and once again if you
check it out
in the database you will find out that
here white has tried various responses
such as Knight to g3 and the Moosey fool
however I'm going to propose one of the
most trickiest mu in this position
namely bishop to have three so not only
we are activating of a bishop and
protecting the defy Knight but if you
look at this position White has occupied
the center with this tremendous Knight
and black has to evacuate them as
quickly as possible the amazing part
about Bishop to f3 is it has been tried
only in two games and that's why this
will be a completely rude shock to your
opponent now if your opponent here
continued with either of the moves such
as Knight to c6 or Bishop to e6 then my
recommendation is you should castle on
the Kings side and I have attached a
sample line in the PG end which will
give you a very good idea how to play
such a positions but more neutral for
any black player is to play the move g6
kicking back this wonderful night get
ready guys because now you are going to
see one of the most amazing trick in
this line namely Knight captures default
BAM
what a move so suddenly white munch upon
and if your opponent doesn't capture the
knight then our knight can safely
retreat back to b3 so the critical
question arise what happens if black
captures this piece afterwards I think
you already see it yup it's Queen
captures d4 attacking the rook the rook
cannot move so the only response is AB 6
and here you can play Knight captures
ab6
but I think the position remain unclear
so as suggested by strong engine my
recommendation here is you continue with
Queen to b6 and no matter however black
plays he will get a lost position so
that is very simple white wants to play
Knight to c7 check so black response is
very obvious black has to play Bishop to
d6 and after that
remember this star moon looked to Devin
and by force now what is winning in all
the variation the only good move over
here is Bishop to e5 however if your
opponent continued it either moves such
as castle on the Kings side or the move
Knight to c6 then the simplest response
is Queen captures d8 doesn't matter
however a black recaptures King captures
d8 and the moonlight to b6 white is
winning the piece back with few pawn in
the backs okay that's fine but what
happens if black plays Bishop to e5
we're here once again the line is very
force we are going to play Queen
captures d8 and after King captures d8
Knight to be six is obvious response
blacks idea is he wants to play King to
c7 and after Knight captures eight black
and calmly play King to say six so for a
time being yes indeed
white is an exchange off but if somehow
black can trap that night in the corner
then black is doing quite good that's
the hope right but we are going to
demolish it with following sequence
Bishop to e2 Bishop to e6
so black wants to capture that piece as
quickly as possible but now comes the
saving resource look to a phone and
however black wriggles
we are going to take of a piece back if
GI then G 3 is a very strong reply and
as per the engine the base sequence goes
as follows Knight to d7 finally black
unleash the attack but white is right on
time as he is going to counter-attack
with F for Bishop captures b2 and now
comes the final breakthrough ePHI so
that is very simple rook to d6 and
nabbing the bishop so Bishop to D files
of his response afterwards we keep
attacking that Bishop with Bishop to f3
and the whole point is after Bishop
captures after de we are not going to
capture that Bishop immediately but
rather giving this intermediate check
rook to d6 which cut the communication
of King and night and after King to c4
and rook captures f3 black still cannot
capture over night as this all night
hanks based black and do over here is
Knight captures Aoife but even after
this move let's say pawn captures defy
Bishop captures ePHI rope to d7 and
after rook captures 8 and rook captures
b7 after the whole transaction it turns
out that white emerge with a clear
exchange advantage okay then let's see
what happens if black capture on f5
which is a most common response at the
low level however I think this is one of
the inaccurate way to handle this
position and is after the simple move he
captures fi white threat is very simple
Bishop to g5 Knight to d5 and giving
some problem in the black camp
so black response is almost force at
this position he has to play defy but
even after this we can simply play
Bishop to g5 attacking gone defy
here black can defend this pawn in a 2v1
he can push forward other one is Bishop
to b4 let's look at the first obvious
response d4 which in fact happened in
12th feeder games but I think after
watching earlier part you already have a
clear-cut idea first we are going to
capture on f6 and after Queen captures
f6 we are going to plonk this knight on
a juicy square Knight to d5 and after
Queen to d8 and the move Bishop to f3
right obtain a great deal of advantage
there is already an x-ray on b7 pawn so
knight c6 is the obvious response and
after that we are going to castle on the
King side amazingly enough even though
this position looks so modest it has lot
of hidden tricks here black has the
obvious response such as Bishop to e7 or
Bishop to d6 but against each of them
White has some devastating reply the
first mu I want to consider is Bishop to
e7 so black is obviously one to castle
on the Kings side as quickly as possible
however after the move rook to even he
should not Castle yup you heard it right
well guess watch a game between two
masters continue with castle on the
Kings side and now why it shows why this
is a great mistake as Knight captures a
7 happen on the board obviously you
cannot capture with the night as ePHI
pawn hangs so black thinks that there is
nothing happening on the board and
simply captured back with the Queen but
what he overlooked is after the
following sequence Bishop captures e6
pawn captures c6 and the Queen captures
d4 suddenly white emerged with an extra
pawn and did in fact when
in this position the highest Lee played
Wu is Bishop to d6 which looks very
obvious but once again White has this
lethal Moo in this position ab6 a
wonderful pawn sacrifice which Believe
It or Not gives some great headache in
the black camp the point is after G
captures f6 white wants to play Bishop
to e4 and generate an attack on the
light squares obviously black and not
castle so in one of the game black
continue with h5 stopping any Queen
intrusion but even after that he does
not prevail White's attacking scheme
namely Queen to have three epochs is a
target and surprisingly enough it is not
easy to defend well you will say why
don't I can simply play Bishop to e7 and
defend everything right well guess what
this is what happened in the game but
after why it's next reply it is very
obvious that black is going to lose this
game very fast
now before I mourn I like you to pause
this video and find out that crushing
move white has played
are you ready did you find this deciding
blow oh and black has to take with the
king yup let's see why he cannot capture
with any piece for example if Knight
captures a seven then Queen to f6 and
White is winning okay then what's wrong
with Queen captures e7 well I hope you
find this tactical resource that is
Bishop capture c6 and now white emerge
with a piece of because if he foolishly
capture this Bishop then after Queen
capture c6 came to f8 and Queen captures
eared white emerge with a whole rook up
so that means whether black liked it or
not but here he has to capture with the
King and once the opponent King is in
the center then you know what to do and
this game is a model demonstration as
white continue with his energetic style
Queen to b3 attacking on b7 and it
doesn't matter whether black continued
with Queen to c7 or rook to b8 let's say
in this game black plays Queen to c7 but
afterwards next reply fo the game is
about to open the major pieces are
coming in the picture very quickly and
the King which is stuck in the center is
a great prey for the whole white camp
last but not least what to do against
Bishop to b4 well I like to show you one
of my own game where my 2388 opponent
played this move and I think this game
give you a clear path how good white
position is I respond very obviously
Bishop captures f6 so black response is
force black has to capture with the Jeep
afterwards I simply castle on the Kings
side renewing the threat on defy my
opponent decided to give me the double
pawn with Bishop capture c3 and after
pawn capture c3 yes indeed both decide
has mutual pawn weaknesses but I think
White has a clear-cut target where black
game is lagging the target for example
in the game black complete his minor
piece development with Knight to c6 I
respond with rook to be even attacking
on b7 and after the move b5
it's a game over time just within 13
boosts why what's wrong with this move
it looks so nice right well the problem
is why it has this nice lever fo which
completely destroy black position my
opponent find nothing better than
capturing on e4 but after that you can
see now the soft target on the d5 square
and I immediately exploited with Queen
to d3 so idea is very simple I want to
play rook to d1 and take on d5 where to
a pawns are not going anywhere
my opponent castle on the Kings side
I played rook to d1 and now he continued
with a 3-2 which I respond with rook to
even I am not in a rush to capture on D
Phi square my opponent finally defends
threat with Knight to e7 but now comes
the tactic guys did you spot it yup it's
c4 so very obvious black cannot capture
on c4 as after Queen to g3 his own Queen
hangs so my opponent plays d4 but after
c3 it is pretty clear that that pawn is
going in a dustbin he tried to be active
on the Queen side with Queen to e5 but
after pawn takes pawn takes
rook takes a three attacking the Queen
Queen captures fi and the Moon Queen
captures d4 at the end of the critical
sequence not only White has a superior
major pieces but black King site is
completely shatter down and in fact
those weaknesses
I have exploited in the middle game and
create a comfortable win that's it guys
I hope you enjoy along this wonderful
tricky line starting with Knight to f5
which will not only surprise your
opponent but if your opponent not
respond accurately which is likely to be
happen then you can win the game very
quickly in the tournament practice thank
you for watching this video feel free to
like subscribe and comment and I'll meet
you in my next episode very soon bye and
take care